Okay
folks, the
same we'll follow the same procedure
that we did for quiz
one. the quizzes. Uh Zoe and Chris are
going to sort the quizzes in
alphabetical order. I'm going to start
grading and I'll let you know when the
quizzes are graded and as I think it'll
be sooner rather than later because I
want to get it out of my office. There
are first quizzes still that still
haven't been picked up. I'm going to
give you three more hours and then they
have to come back into my office because
otherwise it gets too confusing. So if
you haven't picked up your first quiz,
there about 30 or 40 left. Please pick
that quiz up as well. Okay.
So, are we in a
crisis? I promised you. What did I say
at the class? The class life will be
interesting. I said you're going to pick
a company and things can happen during
the course of the next semester where
everything can
change from under you. I don't wish it
on people, but it's happened. It's
happened 2008 this with a fall. It
happened in 2020. It happened in 2001.
And but but what how do we separate a
crisis from just a bump in the road?
What is it that makes for a
crisis? Anybody want to give it a shot?
Because everything is a crisis and on
CNBC. What is it that makes for a
crisis?
There's got to be a trigger action that
can potentially make a big difference
not just in the short term but in the
long term.
Right? 2008 what was the trigger action
that led the crisis to
start? It was the Lehman Brothers
collapse over the weekend. There were
you you know the the the the tween buck
of a series of unfortunate events. There
were a series of unfortunate events
leading up to the Lehman collapse. Bear
Sterns almost collapsing, but the Lehman
collapse essentially was the
trigger. So you have a trigger event.
Then what
happens? Investors react. What's the
only thing you control as an
investor? You don't control what
companies do, what governments do. The
only thing you control
is the price. You you sell. You push the
price down. The minute you push the
price down, we've talked about implied
equity risk premiums. What are you
effectively doing? You're saying, "I
feel more risk. I'm going to demand a
higher
price." During every crisis in the last
15 years, once a crisis gets started, I
compute the implied equity risk premium
every day. I don't do it for others. I
do it for me because that's the only way
I can stay centered. You remember what
it was at the start of this year?
4.33%. On Monday, actually, forget about
Monday. On Wednesday of last week, April
2nd, the implied equity risk premium was
4.57%. So, it already gone up during the
course of this year. Why? Because it's
been a rocky year. So, give me a sense
of direction. 4.57% on Wednesday. What
did the S&P 500 do on Thursday and
Friday in percentage terms?
Down about 8%, 9%. The NASDAQ was down
10%. So the S&P was 9%, the Dow was 8%
and the NASDAQ was
10%. So over a two-day period, your the
index has dropped. So what should happen
to the equity risk premium? Other things
remaining equal? The expected return in
stocks lower price. For the moment, at
least the earnings and cash flows
haven't changed. We'll come back to that
because clearly the tariffs can affect
that. But at least for the moment, the
price of risk has gone up. My Friday
estimate close of trading was
5.08%. Already you can see your cost of
equity for your company has changed over
a two-day period by
0.5%. I'll continue to do it until when?
Until I feel comfortable enough to let
it go. I don't like doing it first thing
in the morning. I'd prefer to drink my
coffee and just read the news. But every
morning I will continue to do this using
the close of trading price. So you'll
track you'll be able to see the implied
premium go
through. So that's the first effect is
you got the price
change and you've if you're pulling
money out of stocks. Remember a lot of
the drop in equity is not cash. It's
basically just a it just goes into thin
air, right? About on Thursday and Friday
collectively, US stocks lost $5.3
trillion in market cap. Global stocks
lost 9 trillion in market cap. Much of
it is just gone into thin air, but some
of it is in cash, right? So, where does
the cash go? If you're feeling scared,
you pushed up the risk premium.
It goes into safe investments or into
things that you think will hold their
value during a
crisis. So, first place I looked was the
treasuries. And guess what treasury
rates did between Wednesday and Friday?
I know what 10-year rate used when you
did your cost of equity, but it was
4.58% at the start of this year. On
Friday, it hit
4.01%. Today, it's actually under 4%.
And that doesn't shouldn't surprise you.
Money goes into treasuries, treasury
rates decrease. So stock prices drop,
treasury rates decrease. And if money
leaves financial assets, where does it
go? Probably
into
collectibles. Most long-standing
collectible, gold didn't go up on
Thursday and Friday, but it held it. If
you have an investment that held its own
in Thursday and Friday, that's a win.
But to me the biggest surprise was
Bitcoin because Bitcoin over the last 15
years has behaved like very risky
stock during the COVID crisis. Stocks
were down 33%, Bitcoin was down
57%. Thursday and Friday it's very early
in the process to pass judgment already.
Bitcoin held its value was up about
1.6%. Clearly people are leaving
financial assets and they're looking for
places to put the money. Totally two
days in, right? So the question is
what's coming? If history is any guide,
there will be aftershocks. If you think
of the tariff announcement and what was
it that made it such a surprise? I mean,
we've been talking about tariffs all
year. So what was it about the Wednesday
announcement that made it such a
surprise?
Yeah. The magnitude and the breadth,
right? Everybody got hit and the amount
was staggering for some of the
countries. You take Vietnam and you look
at the tariff and you say that's
immense. And here's the third reason it
was the basis for the tariffs is
actually not tariffs from the other
country. It's a trade deficit. So if you
had a big trade deficit on a percentage
basis, you got to make a tariff. Why
does it matter? Because it's not going
to be easy for the country to do
something to make a trade. I mean, you
can bring your tariffs down to zero for
US goods, but you can't bring the tra
trade deficit down to how does Vietnam
bring its trade deficit with the US down
to zero. So, it's it's wide, it's deep,
and unless something fundamental is
changed about the way it's computed,
it's not going to be easy to fix. That
was a
surprise. But there will be aftershocks.
Friday, you already saw one aftershock,
right? What did China do on Friday? They
counted. So there is this aftershock of
tariffs create counter tariffs create
tariff. So this could become this
fullscale tariff war in which case every
other day 3 days you're going to and
you're also going to get some positive
aftershocks where some countries kind of
come to an agreement with the US and
maybe the tariffs will be lowered maybe
they won't go away. So there'll be good
news bad news more bad than good if
history is any guide. So for the next
few weeks, welcome to a roller coaster,
right? You're going to get big moves in
either
direction. A thousand points will become
routine. It happened in 2008. We got
used to 200 point moves in the Dow,
which at that time were big moves. But
the Dow at the level it's at, you get
thousand point moves in either direction
within a day.
Will there be a real effect on the
economy? Already likelihood of a
recession has gone up from 25 to 50%. I
mean, macroeconomists usually don't know
what they're talking about. So, I'm not
going to take that too much to the bank.
But clearly, there is going to be an
effect on at least in the near term. Is
there any good news in the near term?
The good news is inflation might become
less of an issue. There might be that
one time no tariff effect but in terms
of oil prices and other commodities a
slower economy does. So in the near term
the economy will slow. Will it go into
recession? We don't know. Unemployment
will probably go up. Consumer confidence
will be
hit. The real question is where does
this all play out long term? And anybody
who claims to know the answer to that is
lying. The one thing we do know is that
global trade was good for global growth.
That the global economy will grow at a
lower rate than it has for the last few
decades because you take global trade
out. It's econ 101, right? There'll be
less real growth, but it'll create
winners and
losers among emerging markets. Vietnam
obviously is far more exposed than
India, China. Why? Because India, China
have large enough domestic markets that
companies can look inward and still be
okay. But if you're I was in Chile last,
you know, on Thursday. What does a
country like Chile do? It's a tiny
country with commodity exports driving
the country. There's not a whole lot of
domestic market can fall back to. So
there's going to be a disparit effect.
And right now, those winners and losers
will still get juggled out. We don't
know what that and that's going to have
a feedback
effect. In
2008, markets dropped the on the first
two weeks, markets dropped 12%. But by
the time you got to 6 weeks out or 8
weeks out, markets had dropped 28%. The
equity risk room started four, went to
eight, stayed
above precrisis premiums for 15 years.
2008 was longstanding. It made a real
effect.
2020 again you started 4.4% 4% February
14th of 2020. That's the there the
trigger was that new story from Italy
saying that they'd found COVID cases in
Italy and they had nothing to do with
China or cruise ships because until then
the delusion we had was it's a pandemic
but if you're not in a cruise ship, you
haven't been to China, you're okay. And
February 14th was the start of the COVID
crisis. By March 23rd, the S&P 500 lost
33% of its value. Treasury rates had
gone from 1.6% 6% to 76% a historic low
but the difference in 2020 is by
September it was almost like it had
never happened in markets we were back
to precrisis levels equity risk pre drop
back so the script plays out in
different ways and after every crisis we
have postcripts right from whom
everybody what's the investor postcript
looking at 2008 and
2020 markets always come back. It's an
extremely dangerous postcript, but they
did right 2008. Look, you know, and you
say, well, I'll just stay through. But
the fact that a catastrophe did not
happen doesn't mean that the probability
of a catastrophe happening was always
zero.
I remember in October of 2020 when
people talked about Morgan Stanley being
the next, you know, the next bank to
fall and then Goldman Sachs was going to
fall. There was a very real chance we've
forgotten in hindsight that you could
have had eight banks in a row fall in
which case what the market was actually
initially bringing in was too negative
that they pro in with co again we again
we wiped our memory clean but I'd like
you to go back and think about how you
felt in March and April of 2020 about
how this was going to play
out but by the time you get to 2021 we
as human beings were capable of looking
back said I knew what was coming. Did
you One of the things I would suggest
you do, it's going to be painful for
some of you, is keep a journal. And this
is something that's a lifelong exercise.
When you get to moments like this, put
in real time how you feel that every
Friday I plan to do this. I plan to put
down this is where I am. This is what's
unsettling me. Because that means you
can't go back and clear your history,
right? You can't say, "Well, I was
always okay." Because I can go back and
look at my March 23rd COVID journal
entry, which I put online, and say, "On
March 23rd, you were terrified. You told
us so." It's good. I mean, the only way
sometimes to be honest with yourself is
by we're making it public, so you can't
pull it
back. I know it's you don't want this.
this doesn't feel like a learning moment
especially as you look forward and say
what will this do in terms of will my
summer internship get yanked because of
this will my because those things are
going to be kind of crowding the
space but you I mean my best learning
has come at a at a cost you know to my
personal portfolio during
crisis so while I plan to feel the pain
I will plan to learn from that pain as I
go through and every Friday for the next
few weeks and as long as this crisis
lasts I will say this is where we are.
So my first post will go up later today.
That's you know partly what I spent last
night writing know. So sometime today
and every Friday I plan to update and
the daily equity risk premium will be on
my web page every day. So as you look at
your cost of equity or capital obviously
you can't hit a moving target. You got
to pick a day to do your cost of
capital. But my suggestion is pick a day
after last Friday. Otherwise, your cost
of equity, cost of capital will become
almost fairy tales because the world has
shifted while you were doing your
project. It's a long assessment, but
we're talking about capital structure,
right? What if something goes wrong?
Perfect lead into what if something goes
wrong? You're bowing. You're deciding
how much to borrow last Tuesday. What if
something goes wrong? Well, we just
discovered what could do go wrong. And
last session we talked about what you
can do. You can ask what if questions.
What if my operating income drops? See
how much your optimal debt ratio
changes. And with Disney didn't change
that much. I could drop the operating
income by 20 30
40%. My optimal stayed at
40%. Here's a second way you can try to
get some downside protection. In my
original assessment of Disney's optimal
capital structure, I concluded that the
optimal debt ratio is 40%. Remember
that? No. And I gave you a cost of
capital
7.19% I think. But I didn't tell you
what rating Disney would have at that
optimal debt. I was just focused on
minimizing the cost of capital. What if
I told you that at the optimal Disney's
rating was double B?
it it isn't, but let's say it was,
right? There's nothing in the cost of
capital that prevents you from going to
a double B rating if it will minimize
your cost of capital. Would you as
Disney be a little concerned about a
double B rating? Leon, help me out here.
What happens when you have a double B
rating? First, what's the magic line you
fell
below? Investment grade, which is triple
B, right? So, that's you fall below
triple
B, you are in trouble, right, Kevin?
What's the trouble of falling below
triple
B? So Derek, I'm sorry, Derek. Sorry.
Yeah, it's that's that's part of it. But
what else happens? First, will there be
a new story the next day that you fell
below investment
grade? Yeah. And then what
happens? Remember the indirect
bankruptcy cost? It all gets triggered,
right? Your suppliers say, "I saw the
news story. I need cash. Your employees
are reading that news story and they're
going on LinkedIn saying, "I might not
have a job soon. Could you please put
out
some feelers to see if I can get a job?"
Your customers read the news story and
if you're producing longlasting
products, they say, "You know what? I'm
not buying from the company." So the
first thing you worry about is hey this
could trigger a kind of meltdown in the
business in the pre981 if you fell below
investment grade another thing happened
you couldn't raise new capital you
couldn't borrow money you couldn't issue
bonds you know Mike Milin and Drexel
Burnham changed that and allowed you to
make original issue bonds but you
couldn't issue bonds so it was
potentially problematic so you can see
why a company might come back to you and
say, "Look, I'm not going to go to your
optimal if it puts me below investment
grade." So, putting an investment grade
rating, I think, is a reasonable
constraint. In fact, you might want to
add a buffer. Say triple B is the
absolute bottom, but I want to give
myself a buffer. I want to be a minus.
Even single
A. Almost every company I've ever talked
to, I don't consult, but that I've
talked to, has had an has a rating
constraint. And most of them have
ratings constraints above investment
grade. But some of them are completely
unrealistic. They say, "We want a double
A. We want a AAA rating." You ask them,
"Why?" It's because a higher rating is
better than a lower rating. Is
it? I remember talking to the CFO of a
steel company in
Europe. And it was the last AAA rated
steel company in the world at the time
that I talked to him. And I said, "What
is this?" And the entire company,
everything that was done in the company
was driven by this rating. So they would
look at a decision say, should we take
that project? How will it affect our AAA
rating? Should we raise capital? How
will it raise? So I said, look,
everything you're doing in this business
is driven by that AAA rating. What's the
big deal about a AAA rating? He looked
at me like I had two heads and say,
well, aa rating allows us to borrow
money at a really low rate.
So I said, "How do you maintain your AAA
rating?" And he told me, he said, "We
never borrow money." I said, "This is
the circular logic that kind of gets us
all into trouble." Right? So you want a
AAA rating because you can borrow money
at really low rate, but the only way you
can preserve that is by never borrowing
money. Zero times a low cost of debt is
still
zero. You might be better off taking an
A+ rating and borrowing some money.
So when you confront a management with
an unrealistic rating
constraint and they say we want a AAA
rating at any cost, rise to the
challenge and give them the bill. This
is how much it's going to cost your
shareholders to maintain a AAA rating.
And it's easy to do with the approach we
have. My cost to capital was
unconstrained, right? My optimal debt
ratio was 40%.
And at that 40% the rating for Disney
that I got the synthetic rating was
single A. Let's say Disney came back to
me and say we want a double A rating. We
prefer a double A rating. You know what
I'm going to do? I'm going to go looking
for a cost of capital that's minimized
subject to that rating constraint. Look
across the spreadsheet. 40% doesn't do
it. But at
30% maybe I can do it. And in the 30%
debt ratio, the value that I get for the
firm is lower because the cost of
capital is going to be slightly higher.
By definition, the optimal was the
lowest cost of capital. I value the firm
at 30% debt and 40% debt, and the
difference is about 5.7 billion. So, I'm
going to go back to Disney and say, you
told me you wanted a double A rating. I
can do that for you, but it'll cost your
shareholders 5.7 billion. They might
say, that's good. We need the buffer.
That's a small enough price to pay. But
then a very conservative me member of
the management group says, "But we would
like a AAA rating." Well, I can do that,
too. 30% puts me at a double A. 20% will
put me at a AAA. Well, you can go to
20%, the cost has now risen to 12.1
billion. My only followup then is I need
you to get in front of your shareholders
and tell them why you're willing to give
up 12.1 billion of their money for you
to have the bragging rights for being
the only AAA rated steel company in the
world or the only AAA rated
entertainment company. You can't stop
managers from doing what they're doing,
but they can at least make them aware of
this is the price you're paying by not
borrowing enough money.
So why should we do it? The answer is
$19 billion. By doing this, you lower
your cost of capital. By lowering your
cost of capital, you get savings every
year. The present value of the savings
is 19 billion. And let's be quite clear,
the 19 billion is a transfer of wealth
from
taxpayers. From a societal standpoint,
it's not a great way to run an economy.
But you have a job. You work at a
company. You got to work with the tax
laws that you have. But remember in all
of the analysis that we looked at, we
borrowed money. And what did we do with
the borrowed
money? We bought back stock, right?
Because I wanted to keep it was a
recapitalization. Disney had big plans
in 2013. They wanted to build a new
theme park in Shanghai. They wanted to
make more movies, buy other movie
studios. Fox was not quite on their
radar yet, but they and that those plans
need a lot of money and seems
counterproductive to go out and borrow
55 in this case, what is it? $40 billion
and buy back stock when you have all
these investment plans lined up. So, I'm
going to play the role of Disney
managers and ask a question. If I borrow
the
money and instead of buying back stock,
I took investments instead, built more
theme parks, made more movies, would my
optimal debt ratio still be 40%. Because
your optimal debt ratio is based on that
premise of buying back stock, I'll give
you a short answer. Yes, if you stay in
the same business mix. So, if all you're
doing is building another theme park,
making more movies, making more
broadcasting shows, I'm okay because
you're essentially expanding your
business, your operating income should
scale up over time. But if you're going
to borrow the money and
enter, I don't know, the AI business,
maybe there's an AI entertainment
business, I'm going to say, wait, you
can't do that because if you do that,
it's a riskier business with negative
cash flows.
your optimal debt ratio is going to
decrease because you're going to use
that debt to enter riskier businesses
that drain your cash
flows. I can't give you a blank check.
And and often when bankers tell a
company you have excess debt capacity
and they leave, that's exactly what
you're doing, right? You're telling the
the company you have the capacity to
borrow money and they read into that I
can borrow money and do an acquisition.
I can borrow money and enter a new
business. And that part doesn't follow.
So if you ask me to do the optimal debt
ratio, I will do it. I'll bring in the
AI business which will be bringing in
more risk or your beta will go up, your
cost of equity will go up with negative
cash flow. So that'll lower the amount
of income I have available to service
debt. I might come back to you and say
if you borrow money and enter a riskier
business, your optimal debt ratio will
no longer be 40%. It'll be
30%. So generically, three questions and
you can see them play out.
So that was
Disney. Let's see what our other
companies look like. Let's move to Tata
Motors next, right? Family group
company, but standalone company. I did
exactly what I did for Disney. I won't
torture you by taking you through the
but it's exactly the same process. Take
the unlevered beta, come up with the
lever bait at every debt ratio. Take the
cost of debt, estimate a synthetic
rating based on the interest coverage
ratio, come up with the cost of debt,
and come up with the cost of capital by
taking a weighted average. What's my
objective in minimize my cost of
capital? And the case of Tata Motors,
that happens at about 20% debt. So the
right mix, the mix that minimizes the
cost of
capital, but Tata Motors is 20% debt,
80%
equity. Motors is actually at about
29%
debt. Not a huge overlever, but clearly
they have too much debt given their
capacity. Now, if this were a standalone
company, what would you do? You'd go to
them and say, "You know what? You need
to bring your debt ratio down. No hurry.
You're not in any distress, but it looks
like you have too much
debt." I did this for Tata Motors,
Tarter Steel, Tata Chemicals. They were
all slightly or or fairly moderately
overlevered. And then I did Tata
Consulting Services, another company in
the same group, and it was massively
underleveled.
Now, this might be just me, but it looks
to me like Tarta Motors, Tarter Steel,
and Tata Chemicals are borrowing money,
and banks are lending the money on the
assumption of what? If the company gets
into trouble, the family will not let
the company go down. They're lending.
It's like lending to a prodigal son
based on the fact that the father is
wealthy, saying, "Hey, he's not going to
let this this son not pay the debt. He's
going to pay it." it it's a dangerous
way to lend because you're lending not
on debt capacity of the person borrowing
but on somebody backing up the
borrower and people did this with Dubai
ports about 15 years ago expecting Abu
Dhabi which is the money bags in the
United Arab Emirate consortium to step
in and back the debt debt comes due the
bankers expect Abu Dhabi to do it and
Abu Dhabi looks at the debt agreements
we don't see a name here it's one of the
most famous. In fact, it's after that
the the ratings for the different parts
of the UAE ended up diverging because
now we have different ratings for Abu
Dhabi, Dubai, and the rest of the UAE
put together because of
that. It looks to me that Tatamotus is
borrowing you, which is good for Tatamot
shareholders, right? So, who's paying
the
price? Who's subsidizing
this? Tata Consulting Service
shareholders. They're the ones who
should be pissed off saying, "Why are
you taking our debt capacity and letting
Tata Motors, Tata, Steel, and Tata
Chemicals, which are companies
completely unrelated to us as investors
do it?" But in family group companies,
don't be surprised to see strange debt
mixes at individual companies because a
family looks at the the entire grouping
of companies, say, "Hey, how much can we
borrow as a group?" but then maybe know
subsidizes some companies by letting
them borrow too much and lets other
companies borrow too
little. Any questions on family group
companies and the subsidy
effect? Then I looked at VA. What's the
big deal about debt capacity for a
commodity company is even if you're a
mature large commodity company, your
earnings are going to go up and down
based on what what the commodity price
does. So I did valet's optimal debt
ratio and at the existing iron or prices
and the exist I came up with an optimal
debt ratio of 30%. That's good
right 30% optimal debt ratio. They were
actually at an actual debt ratio. Their
actual debt ratio was closer to you know
if you look across across time their
actual debt ratio was much higher. the
CFO of Valet for a while was a student
from this class. So I remember I emailed
him and said, "Look, you know, I see
that you have too much debt. What's
going on? Why are you borrowing?" And he
gave me a very sensible answer. I'm not
sure whether it holds up. He said, "We
borrow money not based on last year's
operating income, but the operating
income we can deliver over a cycle."
That kind of makes sense, right? You're
an old company. You have good years, you
have bad years. As long as you set aside
money in the good years to cover the bad
years, you go out and borrow money based
on the average of the
cycle. So that's what we're doing. We're
not overlevered. If we replace the
actual operating income with a
normalized operating income, an average
over time, it turned out that if in fact
if you replace the actual the optimal,
you ended up at the debt ratio closer to
what they had. The logic makes sense.
But if you're a company borrowing
against a
cycle and you're at the down end of the
cycle right now, you're borrowing the
current earnings are not high enough.
What's your biggest worry? Do cycles
always
repeat? Commodity price cycles have been
around. Well, sometimes, most of the
time they do. Thank God for that. But
there are times when the cycle breaks.
The first part of this century, the iron
ore price cycle was broken by China
buying so much iron or to for their
infrastructure that they pushed up the
cycle price on average almost 50% over
previous
cycles. 2013 you still had that China
high in iron or prices. So VA is
borrowing based on an an average price
that's pushed up by China buying huge
amounts. But even China at some point in
time is going to scale down its
infrastructure investment. And if that
happens, you're going to return to a
cycle, but not the cycle you saw over
the last 10 years, but maybe the cycle
over the last century. I mean, how you
normalize is entirely an empirical
question. You might go back the last 10
years, you might go back the last 50
years. So I understand why commodity
companies sometimes borrowed. But take a
look at the longest surviving oil
companies. Royal, Dutch, Exxon,
Mobile. You know how much oil how much
debt they usually
carry? Very
little. 13%, 10%, 15%. Take a look at
the shale oil companies, much younger
companies, they borrow 50, 60,
70%. What did oil prices hit today? They
fell below 60 today. And who knows, they
might be below 50 by the time the week
is over. Those companies that borrowed
money at $80 oil prices expecting this
to continue are now going to be in deep
trouble. There's a reason Royal, Dutch,
and Exxon have survived, which is they
actually borrow money looking at oil
prices saying there will be times when
oil prices drop and stay down and we're
not going to be able to service the
debt. If you're a commodity company,
you're still borrowing money based on
operating income. But whether that
operating income is last year's number,
an average number, the lowest number you
get over the cycle is going to be up to
you. Let's look at
BU technology
company. Lots of growth potential,
right? You're saying, so what? Lots of
growth potential pushes up your market
cap. Remember, our debt ratios are a
percentage of market value, not a book
value. So when I say a 10% debt ratio,
it sounds low, but if your market value
is huge, that debt is also going to be
huge. I mean, I know Nvidia is no longer
a three $3 trillion company, but let's
say it's a $2.4 trillion company right
now. And I say Nvidia should go to a 10%
debt ratio. Doesn't sound like much,
right? But what's 10% of 2.4 trillion?
240 billion. That's a lot of debt. With
high growth companies, small percentage
of debt will translate into large debt
values. And not surprisingly, to look at
the optimal debt ratio for BU, it tends
to be low. I know some of you are
valuing younger companies, growth
companies. When you do the optimal debt
ratio of your company, don't be
surprised to get a really low optimal
debt ratio. Could your optimal debt
ratio be
0%. Yeah. If your if your market cap is
high enough because all I required is
you have a money-making company right it
might make money but it might be a tiny
percent of market cap your optimal debt
ratio can be 0%. It is not unnatural. It
can happen. In that case, you shouldn't
be borrowing money. Your cost of capital
only go
up. And finally, I decide to do my
private business. And here I ran into a
measurement challenge. Remember when I
did the Disney optimal debt ratio, I
started with the enterprise value for
Disney. How did I get that? I took the
market value of equity, added debt minus
cash. A publicly traded company. That's
easy to get. With the private business
though, I run into a problem because
there is no market value of equity. And
here's what you cannot do. You cannot
use the book value of equity. It's not
even a starter in the
game. So to start the process, I had to
make an estimate what how much the
equity in this private business would be
worth. And I cheated. I took a very
simplistic approach. I took the net
income of the company in this case 1.575
million. I multiplied it by the average
P for publicly traded book companies.
You know it's a complete it's a very
rough approximation and used that as my
market value of equity. So when I
computed the enterprise value it is with
this market value of equity 31.5 million
replacing the book equity. Then the rest
of the process flows through just like
the other companies. And here if I
continue to use the total beta the debt
optimal debt ratio is 30%. Again, the
place where you minimize the cost of
capital. Their actual debt ratio was
actually
28%. They're pretty closely their
optimal. But here's the difference in
public and private businesses. Public
companies, when you're significantly
under, I'm going to get in your face and
say, "Hey, this is how much you're
leaving on the table." If you're a
private business and choose not to
borrow money, I'm going to just back
off. I'm going to give you the facts.
They're going to back off because why
aren't you borrowing money? Because this
is your entire wealth. It's tied up in
this company. You have a family. You
have children, tuition to pay, health
care bills coming up. I shouldn't be the
person say go out and borrow money and
then you get into trouble and you go
bankrupt and your children end up in the
streets and I'm going to bl be blamed.
You're a private business. It's your
money. It's your business. If you choose
not to borrow money, that's your choice
to make. I'll give you a sense of how
much you can borrow if you needed to.
But with private businesses, with your
own wealth, you get to make choices that
a manager at a publicly traded company.
So an imaginary at a publicly traded
company says, "Look, borrowing money
makes me
uncomfortable." You know what I'm going
to suggest? A therapist, maybe some
medication, or if you really, really
that doesn't work, quit the job. Go find
a job that makes you comfortable. You're
managing other people's money. You can't
make choices based on this makes me
uncomfortable. I know it sounds harsh,
but it is other people's money and
you're a custodian of that money. You
got to make the best
choices. So the US tax reform act in
2017, we're heading into another tax
reform act. So there will be So you
picked a great year to take corporate
finance. Everything is in motion, right?
2017 two things happened. One is the
marginal tax rate which was 35% was
dropped back to 21%. For those of you
wondering why the tax rate I report for
the US is 25 or 26%. It's because 21 is
the federal tax rate but you have state
and local taxes. But there was a big
drop. So holding all else constant that
alone should make it less attractive to
borrow money. The other thing that
happened and I mentioned this is in 2017
they also put a cap on your interest
expenses which is your interest expenses
if they exceeded 30% of your debit but
you were allowed to take the interest
but you couldn't claim it as a tax
deduction. Both of these things will
work against the tax advantage of debt.
So at least looking at the tax law your
reaction should be oh the amount of debt
at US companies should decrease because
of the tax law. So I've been tracking
dollar debt and debt ratios at US
companies you know from so if you take
Disney I actually right after the tax
law was passed I computed the optimal
debt ratio for Disney tax rate has
changed I was using 38 39 40% I'm now
using and surprisingly the optimal debt
ratio didn't change it stayed roughly
where it was but here's what changed see
the orange line that was my value for
the firm at different debt ratios under
the old tax rate, the higher tax rate.
See the gray? That's the value of the
firm with the new tax rate. So, what do
you notice? At every debt ratio, the
value of the firm I'm getting is lower.
Why? Because I get less of a tax subsidy
from debt than I used
to, which makes sense, right? 35% to 21%
you're getting less tax benefit. Why
isn't it translating to a lower optim?
At least for Disney, it didn't make
enough of a difference to change the
ratio, but your cost to capital effect
is going to be smaller. Your value
effect is smaller even at that same
optimal debt ratio. And collectively, if
you look at US companies, I'm sorry to
do this to you. I really didn't need a
graph. I could have just put it as
numbers, but I just love these fat
column graphs in Excel. Yeah. Okay. So,
if you look at this, this is the total
debt, the green. And if you can look at
over 2017, 18 and 19, the total debt
after the tax code change actually crept
up. So you're saying that doesn't make
sense. Why would companies borrow money?
If I, and this is the problem with if
you come in with a prior, you can very
quickly find something that backs it up.
So if my prior are companies don't care
about taxes when they borrow money, I'd
point to that dollar value of debt and
say, "Look, they're borrowing more
money." But let's say I had a prior that
says companies do care about taxes.
Instead of showing you the dollar debt,
I'd give you the debt to EBA. That's how
much debt you borrowed relative to AIDA.
And that number has decreased over time.
In fact, over the last six years, the
total debt to EBIDA for US companies has
dropped fairly significantly from pre207
levels. So to that notion that this
crisis is somehow caused by companies
borrowing too much money, that does
there's no data to back that up.
companies borrow less money now than
they did pre207 which makes sense
perhaps not by as not as big a drop as
you'd expect but you see it in the total
d so those are all factors to think
about when you think about it now before
you you try the cost to capital approach
in your company and as I said I sent you
the excel spreadsheet you can come up
with the
optimal there are three things about
that tradition I like that cost to
capital approach it's nice it's easy.
It's adaptable. But there are three
limitations. First is because I have to
start with an operating income that kind
of makes it static, right? Because it
takes one year's operating income and
builds an entire castle on. And as we
saw in the last two days, operating
income can be affected by external
events. Second, it does ignore indirect
bankruptcy cost. Right? I take the
rating. I put in the cost of debt. But I
don't factor in that if your rating
drops, your revenues and operating
income could be affected because people
don't buy your goods. And third, it does
make assumptions about betas and ratings
that can give me costs of equity and
debt which are unrealistic, especially
at really high debt ratios. So
conceded, but there's a way in which you
can fix each of those problems. And
that's the second approach and I at
least want to get started. It's called
the enhanced cost to capital approach.
The enhanced cost to capital approach,
there are two things you change. First,
the operating income that I will show
you at every debt ratio will not be
fixed. If you remember the EBIT DA, the
EBIT stayed the same at every debt ratio
for Disney. The original approach here,
I'm going to look at your rating and if
your rating drops, I might actually have
a feedback effect where your revenues
and operating income will also drop. I
have to show you by how much, but your
So, two things go into motion now,
right? When you change your debt ratio,
your rating drops, your cost of capital
will change, but your operating income
will also change. So already you can see
that the optimal debt ratio of your
company might not be where your cost of
capital is
minimized. It'll really be at the where
the value is maximized. The two diverge
because both numbers are in motion. You
can also build in remember we talked
about you know Monte Carlo simulations
when we talked about projects. If you
wanted to get fancier, you could make
this a simulation. See what the optimal
debt ratio looks like given different
hits to the operating
income. So, here's what I did to bring
in that indirect bankruptcy cost. As
long as your rating is up single A or
above, I said there's no effect. Things
are fine. Nobody's going when your
rating drops to A minus. You know, if
you have if you're if you're a pretty
large company, you still have no effect.
You drop to tripleB, you start to see
the first effects. People are starting
to get nervous because you're getting
closer to that investment grade edge.
You dropped to double B+, another five.
So you're saying, where do you come up
these numbers? Well, I might have made
them up, but I make up a reason why I
came up with the numbers. Do companies
sometimes get downgraded? Yeah, I look
at the operating income in the following
year, and if the operating income
decreases, I look on average how much
the operating income decreases. So I
have three groups of companies, low,
medium, and high. And if you're in a
high-risisk company, you can see the
effects are much greater of your
operating income dropping and your
rating
changing. So the the that's going to be
the big difference in this analysis. So
if you want to compare this table to the
table I had with the traditional cost to
capital approach, as my debt ratio
changes, my cost to capital changes. The
cost to capital is minimized still at
40%. But now if you look at the value
effect, it's smaller because I now also
change the operating income at every
debt ratio. So in the case of Disney, I
still get the same optimal debt ratio.
But there are other firms when you
introduce this distress cost in that you
might end up with an optimal debt ratio
lower with this approach than with the
traditional approach. So traditional
approach all you do is focus on
minimizing cost of capital because
everything else stays fixed. You
minimize your cost of capital, firm
value is maximized. The enhanced cost to
capital
approach, you change your debt ratio,
both the operating income and the cost
of capital
change. One final point and I'll set it
up. Is there an optimal debt ratio for a
bank? What do you think? Can a bank be
overlevered? I didn't even know what
that would mean, right? Because banks
borrow money to lend out, but can a bank
have too little
equity? Yeah, that's what regulatory
capital ratios are. So when you think
about banks, it's not do they have too
much debt, it's do they have enough
equity. So with banks, rather than focus
on cost to capital at different debt
ratios, you're focused on what is the
right amount of equity that this bank
has to have. And the regulatory agencies
start you off, right? There's a minimum
regulatory capital ratio. So, it's not
even a choice. You have to have enough
equity to get you above that minimum.
Tier one, tier two, tier three capital.
But if you're a bank and you're a
sensible bank, you're not going to stop
at the minimum. Why? Because you want to
build in a
buffer. The reason you build in a buffer
is bad things can happen. You take a big
loss, a trader goes crazy and loses two
billion. Guess where it comes from? it
comes from your regulatory capital. You
have a big loan that the that the
borrower does not pay back, it comes out
of your regulatory capital. You have a
bad year for the company, you lose
money, it comes out of the regulatory
capital. So there's a regulatory minimum
which you essentially can can look at,
but there's going to be a regulatory
capital ratio that you choose to have.
And if you're a conservative bank, it'll
be much higher than the regulatory
minimum. But the bottom line is debt to
a bank is raw material. It's not a
source of capital. There's no such thing
as the cost of capital for a bank. You
have to stop at the cost of equity. When
banks talk about capital, it's almost
always equity capital. So, next session
we start, I'm going to use that to kind
of come up with what's the right amount
of equity for a bank and what do I do if
I don't have enough equity. I will see
you on Wednesday.
That's
not only 50 or something.
Does it make money? That's one
thing. And uh and it's
You're going to come
around the
It's
just that you have to think about
creative ways of raising equity that
people look past the lawsuits and
things
money
not
even
all right they're raising
money because take home the only
indication
but for a traditional company using war
not that it's a bad thing it seems like
you're giving away something
young world
capital upside. You should that's why
venture capital debt with no option is a
catastrophe.
No matter how high the interest rate is,
you don't get the upside. You get all of
the downside.
capital. Make sure you always add an
option like
how are you?
Yeah.
Maybe in the
morning. Well, I was going to say